[Music]
and
in
fact we are going to tell europe to
join us and that we want to make
things happen so that the people can make their voices heard so
we know that we are where
we are today  today we have a little
the impression of being despised they
impose things on us they impose things on us they force us
things here we are forced
in this case to be vaccinated
to keep our jobs and we don't want
that we don't want  from this oppression
we want to remain a free people
where you are doing there so stop these
marvelous even if we do not sleep we
have the potato we have given up all the energy
to go to the end of things
well the ball
the Canadians have  shared their courage
and
yes
we
geek
[Music]